have you always had crackers no what
changed I dated a white person and what
happened he called me a colored person
not person of color colored colored
person I want to say something maybe
it's just me no no maybe it's just me
how do y'all feel you use the other
accent oh look how do y'all feel let me
yeah there's one which one tell me
when someone approaches they say oh
you're you're a person of color don't
you feel a strong innate desire to spit
in their face because that's a term
that's what they use who's they
who's they often they uh were people of
color oh poof they they say POC bypass
in the news out there yeah but and
they're the worst people and black they
always the worst people and black people
use that [__] too trust oh listen listen
I don't listen and all my Years of
Living this stage that I heard no [__]
ever say people uh you know who it is is
the liberal left-leaning weirdos who say
that kind of [__] people of color what
do you say I say black people I don't
like this whole lumping of everybody who
isn't white people of color
think about that that's large as [__]
they're pretty much lgbtq us
that's what they did
they did and like yo just keep a sec if
you've ever lived in America the racial
groups don't like each other no it's
very segregated so why are you oh people
of color like there's some kind of Ally
[__] sorry that's that's not been my
experience in this States whatsoever if
this is what it felt like
default of others
and they threw everybody in the other
and they're like where's like a badge of
honor people of color suck my nuts why
we haven't even really started this
video but people of color personally I
put I put my life savings on it vast
majority of black people watching right
now gonna hate that term vast majority
of black people anywhere are gonna hate
that term I wouldn't agree but there's a
lot of [__] that use that well
but again the left-leaning people who
cares what these people
who cares we should never abide by what
they want no we don't use uh POC we say
bipark now kill yourself
kill yourself
no I have to just do it by puck they try
to lgbtqia plus two whatever us they
doing the same thing they're taking the
lgbtq model and they keep adding new
stuff you're not wrong so they're gonna
be like uh two spirit bypoc it's like oh
my face
these people are not you're not wrong
you know what you're not wrong I'm gonna
give it to you so all my uh pocs watch
ing like I can't even jokingly do it
because
you know what guys we started this video
with so much negative energy I want to
say welcome hope you guys [__] that you
drew you ruined that [__] no she ruined
it
it's not coming oh that's a good one
well oh my god
um yeah yeah yes yes yes you have a
racial preference from dating not
necessarily but everybody else if my
life says that I do what do they say
your preferences
so
I got two options for you okay I'll give
you three options okay okay so you got a
black B white C Asian all by Mexico what
about Mecca shut up
they don't do so
what in Mexico they absolutely do but
they do all the weird stuff too where
they do the whole cowboy jumping up and
down that's a good that's a good [__]
Hey listen that's a good [__] Hey listen
I would be jumping up and down two of
the cartel was shooting on my feet
let me try to dodge them bullets all of
a sudden they start to happen so black
you say Asian I'm pretty sure anything
Asian oh Asian Asians it's exclusively
Asian guys is there a race that you tend
to date the most she looked like she
like dating men who are confused because
she looked at me she looked like she
like I think blacks black people black
love or Zay I noticed it when I was in
grade school but like she got Nike shirt
she definitely going for [__] oh my
crushes were Mexican all the Mexicans
like yeah
[Laughter]
okay
all right away what you want to do I
love Caucasian women ah this might be
bad for the character
white guys white girls Skies of color
women of color I like how white guys get
their own [__] category there's
people of color see that's the [__] I
don't like
let's go I agree as much as I would like
to say that I don't when I made my if
there's anything but white I'd be
shocked I was definitely only trying to
match with certain people it was pretty
an uncomfortable feeling
because I then I painted myself as a
racist
I didn't realize she felt guilt about
her preference the only reason you feel
that kind of guilt is because it's only
white
oh my God
I always like white men
Hillary Clinton am I racing
a lot of people are attracted to people
that look like them you like who you
like I don't think you should be forced
to like someone just because it might
seem racist or not you're like racist to
have racial presence I'd say yes there
is a problem with having racial
preference I think it's intentional and
it's like I won't date any Hispanic
people I feel like that's rooted in
racism most people when they try to
avoid a particular race if you dig into
their past they must have gone through
some bad experiences I have like
internalized racism and like
anti-blackness and like all these things
that I have to continue to process and
work through I don't understand in
solidarity with everyone in this country
is that something wrong with having a
racial preference I think if it's a
fetish fetish fetish then yeah probably
but I think that if you are looking at
them in a wholly sexualized fashion that
veers into racism do you have a racial
preference I like my black men that
contrasted that skin color it to me is
very erotic
you have a racial preference when dating
no no I don't discriminate people think
I do but I don't I've never said I'll
turn down someone because of their race
I love all ethnicities I think they're
all [__] hot what's your ethnicity I
am South Indian South Indians no
I think a lot of people got preferences
and don't know it yeah I think a lot of
people got preferences and have it for
the wrong reasons aka some Prejudice or
some bad experiences which you're
entitled to and I think some people have
some preferences and they're Justified
me parsley I'll tell you date whoever
you want to date for whatever reason you
want to date however you want to date
and that's where I stand you want to be
with a white girl you wanna do this
whatever that's fine I got no problem
with it what do you think there's
certain things that I personally don't
like I don't like hearing I don't like
for for what it represents for me but
other than that I'm not gonna go in if
that's what you like that's what you
like grown adults doing their things do
your thing man whatever let us know what
you guys think in the comments below we
want to hear from you
the contrast of the colors
yeah yeah